well Ellen I have I have a couple more
questions for you but first I just
wanted to ask you did mention the
Covenant House and also Yale that you
feel sharp would be give to but what
other organizations do you support oh
gosh you're putting me on the spot I
support well I support my children's
educational institutions because they're
both actually in a private educational
institution I support I'm drawing a
blank there is one other that I give
significant money to every year and I
forgot what it is no I'm great well i
can i can but its targeted i mean it's
really in what I consider to be a
significant amount of money to you know
three or four organizations and I still
will support you know friends who were
doing the polar bear plunge you know ray
support is their favorite thing
occasionally so it's not like I don't
give any money to anything else but I
really feel like it's better to have a
bigger impact in a place by giving more
to do all I think that's really
interesting because you know as a class
we're dealing with you know who which
organization are we going to support and
I think it's really interesting that you
support the Covenant House it has you
know has had its ups and downs and also
Yale which is a huge organization that
receives a lot of money each year so and
I know Stephen touched on this a little
bit but what advice do you have for us
as a class that is you know looking into
huge organizations but also looking
locally into small organizations like
the Columbus house that is you know that
then you know not the Covenant House but
it's around its around New Haven and
it's a smaller organization but we're
also looking at against malaria
foundation which is in Africa that is is
a huge organization that supports a lot
of a lot of children so what if I see a
friend yeah i mean it's it's hard to
make those decisions well i think it's
useful to think about you know what your
mission is you know i think for me i
decided that i would pick a couple of
things that i wanted to promote they're
mostly in the education related area
although covenant houses in
exactly in that and you know I I don't
know I think it's a really hard question
because you have to decide are you going
to are you going to support something
that has a broad reach and a broad
impact but maybe not as as high an
impact necessarily we're going to
support something that has a real focus
and is in your own community you know
this is this is a real debate do you
support something across the ocean do
you suppose so something next door we
have this debate foreal service did we
do all of our trips abroad or should we
start doing trips in the US there's so
much to be done you know the better
question might be can you develop some
kind of philosophy or mission that you
can stick to you know that's that's
really and you're in a sort of unique
situation you're not an organization
that's going to go on for a long time
with this so i think i think it is very
difficult but I do actually think that I
don't know if you have the option of you
know giving a lot of little bit of money
to a lot of different things I do think
that a lot of money to a small one or
two organizations is probably has more
of an impact thank you sure well Ellen
thank you so much for sharing your
insights and your time and talent you're
laughing I'm so happy to do it with our
students and thank you students for
those really searing questions of our
guest Ellen Gibson McGinnis the chairman
emeritus of the Yale Board of Governors
it has been a wonderful can someone move
the teleprompter to the end from I'm now
turning to the camera so this is just my
closing okay maybe maybe I won't even
read this just let me see what I had
written
okay okay scroll this a little bit
scroll circle read the whole thing
scroll I'm just reading I'm just go on
you can go a little okay Thank You Ellen
for sharing your time and talent with us
today it is so important to have people
give their knowledge to help us with
these difficult questions in this time
of great inequality and also great
wealth to help change the world and
thank you students for your insightful
answering questions of our guest Ellen
Gibson McGinnis the chairman emeritus of
the Yale Board of Governors it has been
wonderful doing today's program on
philanthropy and action l insured with
us how important is to be passionate in
supporting organizations that are making
a difference and I ask you what are you
doing to change the world